let me tell you a story about guo when
we who is a chinese billionaire he's
trumped like in many ways right and not
just the alleged sexual harassment and
bribery but also growing we is a
bombastic delusional wild user of social
media
so he's like trump and some pretty
interesting personality ways he fled
china three years ago in 2014 when he
learned he was about to be arrested he
was accused in china of being involved
in kidnapping rape and bribery and he's
now living in a very modest sixty seven
million dollar apartment in new york
city
I assure you it's in a fantastic New
York City neighborhood
China wants him back right but there's
no extradition treaty between the United
States and China so there's no real
legal mechanism to just send when we
back to China we know Trump is aware of
this guy there was a meeting at the
White House over the summer and Mike
Pence was in the room Jared Kushner was
in the room Steve Bannon was in the room
and Donald Trump said to them that he
was aware of a Chinese criminal that the
United States should deport he actually
said during the meeting where's that
letter that Steve brought we need to get
this criminal out of the country the
letter that Donald Trump was referring
to was a letter that RNC Finance
Chairman Steve Wynn brought to him this
is the same Steve Wynn who's the casino
mogul write that same Steve Wynn brought
a letter to Trump about grow when we
saying we got to get him out of the
country Steve Wynn whoa I'm getting so
worked up here that I'm almost punching
the mic again Steve Wynn probably has
his own reasons to want grow when we out
of the country but that's a story for
another day
Trump was set to deport him he was going
to deport grow but he was talked out of
it and part of talking out a Trump out
of it involved telling him that grow
when we is a member of Donald Trump's
mar-a-lago resort that's the resort that
has a two hundred thousand dollar
initiation fee and fourteen thousand
dollars a year in yearly dues remember
pay to play I guess this is pay to stay
whoa when we is a member at the
president's resort and he is no longer
getting too
and this is a super specific example of
how Donald Trump's business interests
are causing conflicts of interest right
if Trump truly divested from mar-a-lago
would he care or be influenced by Gwang
Lee's membership in mar-a-lago I guess
not presumably if Trump had sold morrow
logo to one of his friends then maybe
yeah he would still have that conflict
but maybe not right the concept of a
blind trust Trump knows that he owns
mar-a-lago there is no way you can do
anything approximating a blind trust
that would actually apply to trump and
merrill ago because he knows he owns it
and he's going there on a regular basis
and speaking of mar-a-lago mar-a-lago is
still not keeping proper visitor logs we
don't even know who's going tomorrow
Lago and what deals could be coming from
it so while we know about growing we and
the fact that all of a sudden Trump has
no more interest in deporting him we
have no idea what cronyism and
pay-to-play might be going on because we
don't even know who's visiting trump's
resort mar-a-lago now back to grow when
we I know people will hear the story and
some of you will email me and you'll say
you know David it's not that clear that
gwanghui is that bad of a guy it's
possible that China has completely
trumped up these charges with a
political witch-hunt because they don't
like the fact that this is a dissident
that's a fair argument right you can
argue that growing we shouldn't be
deported because hey after all he's not
been convicted of any crime it might be
a political witch-hunt and we have no
extradition treaty but that's a separate
issue from the reality that months ago
Trump wanted him out Trump was set to
deport grow when we and now
coincidentally right after it's found
out and Trump is told by the way the guy
you're about to deport is a member of
your $14,000 a year two hundred thousand
dollar initiation fee Resort in Florida
Trump no longer wants to get the guy out
so make the argument you want about grow
when we that's not the argument that
Donald Trump is making it's the
mar-a-lago membership that through the
deportation
on its face during the swamp huh drain
the swamp give us a life like on
Facebook facebook.com slash david pakman
show we'll take a break and I'm gonna
come back with a really horrible story
about a former Milo you know polis
intern who killed his own father for
calling him a Nazi back after this